we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting little idea from the
voicemail today
hey dave a great idea for you run for
president in 2020 okay if you win you
win and if you lose you can go back to
the show with dignity you will raise the
media media interest in your show
subscribers will double I guarantee it
you will have absolutely no problems
getting members because you will be a
face of a full face for the Democratic
Party really wouldn't DMV announcement
you're on the United State couple
problems couple problems with that first
and foremost I wasn't born in the United
States so I can't run for president also
don't you have to be 37 years old Pat to
run for president 35 which you will be
though it's really the only the only
thing Mac is being born outside the
United States but Ted Cruz ran for
president so that's still an open
question to yeah hey listen I might as
well run right I mean Obama was
president after all if if that's uh that
the the argument and maybe I actually do
have a shot no I mean I can't run for
president and maybe the Schwarzenegger
rule if it ever becomes a reality
someday will allow me to run for
president but not today not for 2020 we
will talk about 2020 on today's bonus
show and much more become a member
become a patron please sign up and we
will speak to you on the bonus show